let's talk about data fabrics and why
it's critical to understand the concept
of a data fabric in today's world
so to start a data fabric is not a
single piece of technology
in fact it's a holistic data and ai
strategy
to leverage all existing investments
and future investments within your data
estate
a simple strategy to understand and
follow is the ai ladder
which is about the collect organize
analyze
and infuse of all enterprise data to
create
better more compelling customer
experiences produce better services and
products
as well as improve business operation
efficiency so why is understanding what
a data fabric is
today so critical well we're entering a
new technology era
now the biggest challenge within the
knowledge era is going to be closing the
gap
between the available data and
information
and how much of that is actually turned
into knowledge and insights
to be able to produce more personalized
compelling customer experiences more
dynamic cutting edge products and
services
and improve overall business operation
efficiency so what stops businesses from
closing that gap
on the available data that they have
well technology plus
scale plus people equals complexity
that's not necessarily a bad thing what
is a bad thing is when that complexity
of boundaries between the technologies
people
and the vast scale of data gets to a
point where
not much is able to get done and that's
where we're sitting today
that's why there's so few businesses
that are able to
close that gap so how does the data
fabric help
there's three key areas the first is a
data fabric allows access to all
data sources types and domains
especially in a multi-hybrid cloud
strategy the second is it thinks
holistically
thus it's able to create efficiencies
throughout collect
organize analyze and infuse to be able
to process
and leverage data significantly faster
the last part is enforceable policies
business wide
now if you're able to access a lot more
data and you're able to leverage it a
lot faster
it's even more critical to ensure that
the right people
are accessing the right data at the
right time so a data fabric strategy
presents
many benefits to an enterprise the first
one being
cost and time savings for many of the
processes businesses
have going today and that alone should
be reason enough to start thinking
strategically about a data fabric
strategy
so to summarize a data fabric is all
about leveraging people
and technology to close the gap of
available data to knowledge a company
has
in order to produce more compelling
customer experiences more dynamic
products and services
and improve overall business efficiency
if you like this video and want to see
more
please like and subscribe and if you
have any questions please drop them in
the comments section below